hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
with the match Magnus Carlsen versus
onigiri and this is Game two of their
match Game one ended in a draw not a lot
of fireworks there so I decided to skip
that one but a lot of fireworks here and
here Giri repeats the line cousin
already played against future in this
tournament but with with a little twist
so without further ado let's check it
out so Magnus with the white pieces goes
for his d4 as he's been playing the
entire tournament we have 9 12 6 c4 and
c6 now we have Knight to f3 and the d5
the Queens gambit declined is on the
board and Knights the C theory we've got
to before the error goes in defense and
C chapters on d5 so everything the same
as in cousins game against future
Knights the e4 Giri copies villagers
game we have looked the c1 and now
Knight to c6 we have night study to end
there in that video will recover futures
game we mentioned that the g5 is is the
option that everyone's talking about NBS
here a Giri also goes for it the Shabak
the e3 and and now comes Knight captures
on c3 we covered why not Bishop to g2 in
that game so Knight captures and c3b
captures and Bishop to e3 going after
the rook rook the b1 and now f5
preparing f4 we have g3 and up until
this point it's the exact same game
Crossing played against fuchsia and here
if you lose your castle to prepare for
and so on
but Giri goes for Bishop to d6 and it's
a new move in the position so as I move
12 we have a completely new game and
here the question is what happens now if
f4 and Collins Bishop gets drafted but
Carlsen immediately plays a rook to g1
here and this really put Geary into a
deep sink as obviously Geary didn't look
at it at home while preparing the
variation Giri saw that f4 traps the
bishop but obviously he didn't check
root 2 G 1 as it's quite the quite the
wild line point is that if you push f4
it is very much playable then Carlsen
gives up the bishop and goes for Bishop
captures an F for Bishop captures and
now III opens up the
from the Queen to the to the black king
and after Queen to e7 just pinning that
e3 pawn now Queen h5 check King goes
here captures here and it's a really
crazy position where anything can happen
Bishop goes back so you don't worry
about it anymore and now any any any
move can it can be played here efore
Bishop b3 you can develop the rookie and
play with the night and who knows at
what depth across and looked at his rook
to g1 move so the hero gear we spent
some seven minutes which is a lot as it
is a fifteen minute game so after those
seven minutes ago we decided not to
capture it and he decided to castle
instead and Carlsen immediately goes for
h4 I so just threatens to open up the G
file and Jia Giri finds a very tricky
way of how to keep the G file close he
plays f4 we have G captures an f4 and
now g4 the point is nicely protected and
will be further protected with h5 so
keeping the G file closed
well cousins King is still in the center
of the board and really not not clear
what what he will do with it we have
looked a b5 by Magnus going after the d5
pawn and here just Knight to e7
defending the pawn and now Magnus finds
this well very interesting f5 move point
is that if you captured with the bishop
the rook just captures on b7 and if you
capture it with the night then well then
the bishop no longer defends the g4 pawn
so just captures and you cannot reach it
just captures here with check so very
interesting f5 idea and of course if
rook captures it then you just have rook
captures energy for check once again as
the rook now blocks it
so after f5 with h5 by Gary now
defending the point here now ready to
capture on f6 sorry on a5 and now Bishop
to g5 again preventing the knight from
capturing and here you could capture
with the rook but then you allow white
to this c4 which comes with temple as it
comes with an attack on the rook so you
would be forced to capture and so on so
instead of Giri goes c6 pushes the rogue
back first rook to b2 and only now rock
actress here so you don't have to worry
about
efore in the rugby on b5 so efore by
Magnus and
now point is if you go back with the
rocket then that's a problem if I've
comes you block the dark square bishop
and your position is just much better
now you can even open up the position
here try and get an attack started
against the black King
so instead after E 4 we have rook
captures on g5 by giri so here giri
gives up the exchange but he will get an
excellent outpost for his night and on
f4 and the call since the rooks aren't
really doing all that much so it doesn't
make sense to give up this exchange so H
captures in now Knight to g6 with E 5 by
Magnus and now Bishop to f8 we have
night
sorry Bishop to d3 attacking the knight
and now Knight to f4 and this is now a
beautiful outpost for this night Knight
the f1 and I just remembering the Queen
o also defends the knight and Queen
captures and g5 and here we reach our
critical moment we reach almost our
position from the thumbnail here your
knight is Android the bishop is under
attack and it's kind of a good bishops
or
moves like the bishop to b1 are to be
considered Knights to e3 also an idea
but mainly moving the bishop out of
harm's way but here across and played f3
which makes sense you kind of want to
open up the G file however f3 blunders
the game completely so feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out why blunders the game while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that the
rook and b2 is undefended and for those
who just want to enjoy the show
it's just Knight captures and III with
check and now of course if you don't
capture the night you're just gonna lose
the route either way so Magnus captured
the night but now Gary played Queen to
see one with check and now off go to the
rook so King f2 Queen captures and BT
with check and Knight study to blocking
but now our Giri
when he just grabbed a full rook now
just continues attacking on Bishop to a5
forces Magnus to capture so characters
and now Gary can capture with check King
g3 and now Queen captures in c3 so just
continue the game grabbing up on and the
Giri sacrifice the exchange so now by
grabbing the rook means that
he's actually up a piece which is which
is not a bad deal
King gage for by Magnus and now Queen
captures on d4 we have looked the g3 by
Magnus but now Bishop to g7 going after
the e5 pawn Magnus defends it but now
rook to f8 and it was in this position
unmoved 33 that Magnus Carlsen resigned
the game and Geary gets his second
victory in the tournament against none
other than a world champion Magnus
Carlsen so it's a giri who's leading the
match now and it's Magnus who has to
strike back to get get back into the
match otherwise he is in danger of
losing first place in the tournament
well in the standings for the moment so
we'll see how it goes will he be able to
win at least one and take it to our
mageddon
or will maybe Geary win more games we'll
just have to wait and see yeah here here
we resign as there's nothing nothing
really to do once you move the Queen you
can just grab the f4 pawn and there's
just no compensation here black ass I
mean black is still up a bishop and
white is without an idea so once again I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
think I'm on LaGuardia and Michael Reid
Chris Picard mark Gupta and the Don
putti for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video serum thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continue in the
coverage of the Magnus invitational
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Sunday